[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Dessert,
was sich viele gewünscht haben,
weil sie es oft in meiner Story gesehen haben:
Erdbeer Eton Mess.
Das ist ein Dessert aus Baiser,
aus Strawberries, also Erdbeeren,
und Creme, also Sahne.
Und das ist ein englisches Dessert.
Ich habe es hier in meinem Backbuch
"Backen für jeden Anlass" drin
und habe es da ein bisschen verfeinert mit Schokolade.
Wartet, ich zeige es euch.
Wo habe ich es?
Mit Schokolade!
Schokoladen Eton Mess!
321.
Ich neige immer dazu Eto Mess zu sagen,
weil ich dachte es wäre französisch,
aber es ist Eton Mess,
englisch.
Lecker!
Mit frischen Erdbeeren!
Und das ist einfach ein Dessert,
was man...
Also es sieht total schmuddelig eigentlich aus,
aber wunderschön,
weil es eine Baiserplatte ist,
die auf dem Blech gebacken wird,
und dann kommt da einfach ein bisschen Creme drauf,
also Sahne,
Erdbeeren drauf,
fertig!
Und es ist wirklich mega, mega lecker!
Und so sieht es im Buch aus.
Also.
Und ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, ich zeige euch das Dessert,
das Grundrezept, weil wirklich viele danach gefragt haben.
Dafür braucht ihr
vier Eiweiß,
eine Prise Salz,
200 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und einen Teelöffel Stärke.
Ja.
Und das ist hier sozusagen das Grundrezept.
Ihr könnt natürlich Vanilleextrakt austauschen
durch Tonkabohne zum Beispiel.
Oder ihr könnt noch Schokolade dazu geben.
Im Buch habe ich dann einfach noch
Zartbitterschokolade geschmolzen und mit untergehoben.
Also da gibt es wirklich Variationsmöglichkeiten.
Ganz klassisch ist es wirklich
nur mit Baiser, Sahne und Erdbeeren.
Heute machen wir es aber auch
ein bisschen anders verfeinert.
Also jetzt gebt ihr das Eiweiß in die Rührschüssel.
Das Eigelb könnt ihr aufheben
und was anderes daraus zubereiten
oder auch einfrieren zum Beispiel,
Buchteln backen
oder ein anderes Hefegebäck.
Jetzt kurz steifschlagen, Eiweiß und Salz.
Die Mini ist so süß!
Heute wollte ich mal mit der Mini arbeiten.
Ich bin noch so müde.
Sieht man das an meinen Augen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Schon, nicht?
>> SALLY: Es war gestern ein langer Tag im Shop
in Mannheim.
Ich glaube, das sieht man.
Ich bin eingeschlafen vor Samira und Ela!
Ich habe gesagt: "Kommt, Mädels, ich bringe euch ins Bett."
Und dann bin ich in Elas Bett eingeschlafen.
Ja.
Und Ela ging runter und sagt:
"Papa, Mama ist in meinem Bett eingeschlafen!"
Okay.
Und heute morgen habe ich den Wecker, glaube ich,
viermal nachgestellt
und ich bin immer noch müde.
Irgendwann werden sie wach, die Augen.
Perfekt!
Eiweiß ist schon steif.
Jetzt gebt ihr einfach langsam hier den Zucker dazu
und rührt dann die Baisermasse
für etwa acht bis zehn Minuten weiter,
bis sich der Zucker auflöst.
[Musik]
O mein Gott!
Guckt euch diese Baisermasse an!
Ich könnte sie gerade
löffeln.
Wirklich löffeln!
Mmh!
Yum, yum, yum!
Okay.
Wichtig ist jetzt, dass euer Ofen vorgeheizt ist
auf 190°C Heißluft.
Wenn ihr keine Heißluft habt,
könnt ihr auch Ober-/Unterhitze nehmen.
Aber das Problem bei Ober-/Unterhitze ist einfach, dass
die Baisermasse dann dunkel wird.
Also ich will ja eher, dass sie trocknet,
und nicht, dass sie backt.
Wählt dann vielleicht nur 150°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und gleich wird der Ofen sowieso runtergestellt,
damit eben die Masse nicht verbrennt.
Aber ich brauche am Anfang kurz diese große Hitze.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Stärke kurz dazu sieben.
Das ist übrigens Maisstärke
so wie
eigentlich
zu 90 Prozent.
Also alles, was ihr so als Speisestärke kauft,
– könnt ihr mal darauf nachlesen –
ist meistens Maisstärke.
Also ist dieses Rezept auch glutenfrei.
Jetzt noch ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt da rein.
Mmh!
Und nur kurz unterheben.
Und die Masse kommt jetzt hier auf ein Backpapier.
Ich nehme jetzt Backpapier.
Backfolie geht zwar auch,
aber dann verlängert sich die Backzeit ein bisschen,
weil die Backfolie eben das Gebäck nicht austrocknen lässt,
was ja normalerweise ein guter Vorteil ist.
Aber hier möchte ich einfach,
dass die Baiserplatte eben auch schön durchtrocknet.
Also die wird nicht komplett trocken
wie Baiser vom Bäcker zum Beispiel.
Die ist innen so marshmallowartig
und außen knusprig.
Also die ist...
Der Josh kriegt schon große Augen!
Die ist echt der Hammer!
Jetzt hier einfach so ein bisschen verteilen
zu einem großen Rechteck.
Und ich werde jetzt gleich
die Masse noch in vegan zubereiten.
Denn das wollte ich die ganze Zeit schon ausprobieren.
Das probieren wir jetzt einfach zusammen aus.
[Musik]
Das Rechteck ist jetzt etwa 30 mal 35 cm groß.
Jetzt gehe ich direkt an den Backofen.
Und da stelle ich jetzt den Ofen gleich von 190°C Heißluft
auf 110°C herunter.
Zack.
Das Ganze für etwa 40 bis 45 Minuten.
Und, wie gesagt, wenn ihr mit Ober-/Unterhitze backt,
von 150°C runterstellen auf etwa,
ich würde mal sagen, 90°C.
Und hier habe ich jetzt einen Backofen,
der hat eine Dampffunktion.
Aber das ist kein Volldampfbackofen.
Volldampfbackofen ist bei mir hier rechts.
Und da müsst ihr auch darauf aufpassen.
Denn in einem Volldampfbackofen
habt ihr die Dichtungen außen herum.
Und die sind wirklich komplett dicht,
denn man tut ja komplett dampfgaren.
Das heißt, es kommt keine Feuchtigkeit raus.
Also, wenn ihr einen Volldampfbackofen habt,
geht ihr dann her
und macht ungefähr zweimal,
also so alle 15 Minuten ungefähr,
den Backofen auf, lasst kurz die Feuchtigkeit raus,
dann Backofen wieder zu.
Hier habe ich jetzt nur Dampfstoßbackofen.
Das ist okay.
Ich lasse hier jetzt aber auch, glaube ich,
einmal zumindest so die Feuchtigkeit raus.
Denn das macht wirklich einen Unterschied
und die Baisermasse, die kann dann eben nicht trocknen.
Also da ein bisschen darauf achten.
Musste ich auch feststellen.
Als ich mal Baiser gemacht habe im rechten Backofen,
im Volldampfbackofen,
ist die Baisermasse nicht getrocknet,
sondern aufgeplatzt.
Das wäre jetzt hier nicht schlimm.
Aber, wie gesagt, dass ihr da mal den Unterschied kennt.
Und jetzt machen wir das Ganze noch vegan!
Also wir probieren es.
[Musik]
Für die vegane Version braucht ihr im Prinzip
die gleichen Zutaten außer Eiweiß natürlich.
Und statt Eiweiß von Hühnern
nehme ich jetzt einfach Eiweiß aus Kichererbsen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier jetzt eine Dose Kichererbsen.
Und das Wasser, was man normalerweise wegschüttet,
das sind Proteine pur!
Damit habe ich auch schon Mousse au Chocolat hergestellt
in veganer Version.
Und dieses Wasser ersetzt sozusagen mein tierisches Eiweiß.
Und davon nehme ich jetzt einfach die gleiche Menge.
Das heißt, ich wiege das ganz kurz ab.
Ich rechne immer pro Eiweiß ungefähr mit 35 Gramm.
Bei vier habe ich also 140 Gramm.
Und aus den Kichererbsen
mache ich für uns später ein Hummus!
Ich denke, dieses Kichererbsenwasser
kann man auch ganz gut einfrieren.
Also, wenn ihr mal Kichererbsen benutzt,
aber gerade keine Verwendung habt für das Wasser,
könnt ihr es wahrscheinlich auch super einfrieren.
Und das wird jetzt hier auch aufgeschäumt
und auch aufgeschlagen.
Und das funktioniert tatsächlich richtig gut!
Einfach auch mit Salz.
Also hier kurz steifschlagen
und dann wieder den Zucker dazu geben
und genauso verfahren, wie gerade eben.
Da dachte ich echt so,
als ich das das erste Mal gemacht habe:
Krass!
Wie echtes Eiweiß!
Es riecht nur ein bisschen nach Kichererbsen.
Aber der Geschmack, das verschwindet.
Also es schmeckt echt mega gut!
Jetzt probiere ich es nur mit dem Backen aus.
Das habe ich noch nicht probiert.
[Musik]
Die könnte man jetzt sogar bedenkenlos löffeln!
Kein rohes Eiweiß.
[Musik]
Also eines muss ich jetzt sagen,
so allein vom Feeling her
fühlt es sich an wie ganz normale Baisermasse.
Also wirklich
kein Unterschied!
Okay.
Josh, du darfst mal probieren, okay?
So.
Jetzt ist es halt keine Blindverkostung mehr.
Aber probier mal,
ob die vegane Baisermasse
genauso schmeckt.
Und?
Gut?
>> JOSH: Wahnsinnig gut!
>> SALLY: Würdest du jetzt rausschmecken,
dass es Kichererbsenwasser war?
Oder...
>> JOSH: Überhaupt nicht!
>> SALLY: Schmeckt es wie Baiser?
>> JOSH: Ich habe jetzt nicht den Direktvergleich.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich hätte was aufheben sollen.
>> JOSH: Aber
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: du könntest mich damit
>> SALLY: Füttern?
>> JOSH: irreführen.
>> JOSH: Würdest du mir sagen, das ist normaler Baiser,
>> SALLY: Okay. Krass!
>> JOSH: ich würde es sofort glauben.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde, auch hier,
guck dir das mal an!
Ich bin jetzt mal gespannt.
Ich hoffe, dass es sich beim Backen genauso verhält.
Ich bin gespannt.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Bei mir ist die Baiserplatte schon bereit.
Und, wenn sie sich vom Backpapier leicht ablösen lässt,
ist sie fertig.
Also das ist so die Probe, ob sie fertig ist oder nicht.
Ich ziehe sie jetzt hier direkt auf ein Abkühlgitter.
So kann sie gut abkühlen.
Mh.
Ist wahrscheinlich heiß.
Und dann gucken wir gleich noch nach der veganen Platte.
Die Baiserplatte sieht wunderbar aus!
Sie ist perfekt abgekühlt.
Die vegane ist noch im Backofen.
Die backt etwas länger als diese hier.
Also ich gucke mal, ob sie gut genug durchtrocknet.
Ich habe auch die Temperatur etwas erhöht.
Ich glaube, die braucht einfach mehr Hitze.
Jetzt kann ich hier mein Dessert fertigstellen.
Zur Fertigstellung nehme ich also noch
250 Gramm Magerquark,
200 Gramm Schlagsahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
250 Gramm Erdbeeren,
jeweils 150 Gramm Blaubeeren und Himbeeren
und etwas weiße Schokolade.
Also das kann kurz zur Seite.
Und
ihr seht, ich brauche jetzt hier auch keinen Zucker.
Denn die Platte ist ja jetzt süß genug.
Und deswegen muss jetzt die Sahneceme
– ich mache jetzt eine Sahne-Quark-Creme,
weil uns das so gut schmeckt –
eben nicht so ganz süß.
Das gleicht es dann nämlich perfekt aus.
Ich probiere es.
Ich glaube, es spritzt raus.
Ich probiere es nicht.
Ich...
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein!
Da kann man vielleicht eine größere Schüssel nehmen.
Plups!
Und hier kommt jetzt geschmacklich
nur etwas Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Im Winter könnt ihr das Dessert
auch zum Beispiel mit Zimt verfeinern
und eher so winterliches Obst nehmen,
Bratapfel zum Beispiel.
Bestimmt auch mega lecker!
Jetzt hier kurz steifschlagen.
Es muss jetzt auch keine feste Konsistenz sein.
Jetzt kommt die Creme hier direkt drauf.
Das würde ich jetzt eigentlich
dann wirklich so kurz vor dem Verzehr machen.
Also es ist auch okay, wenn es mal ein bisschen durchzieht,
aber jetzt nicht für den nächsten Tag vorbereiten.
Die Platte könnt ihr vorbereiten
und dann wirklich nur noch die Creme machen.
Die Creme ist jetzt auch nicht ganz steif, wie ihr seht.
Guckt. So ein bisschen weicher.
Das ist auch völlig okay.
Ich habe auch extra kein San-apart dazu oder Sahnesteif,
damit es eben schön weich bleibt.
Jetzt ein bisschen verteilen.
Und dann ergänzt sich einfach diese Baisermasse, die süß ist,
die cremige Konsistenz vom Topping,
die Früchte noch drauf
perfekt!
Und da werde ich gleich bei der veganen Variante
einfach vegane Sahne nehmen.
Die schmeckt mir persönlich zwar nicht so gut.
Vielleicht liegt es an der Marke. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber die hat einfach so einen bitteren Nachgeschmack.
Aber ich finde sie
für eine vegane Alternative echt ganz gut.
Probieren wir auch gleich.
Die Erdbeeren werden jetzt geviertelt
und kommen hier drauf.
Die übrigen Früchte gebe ich so drauf.
[Musik]
Das Schöne an diesem Dessert ist,
es gibt kein Richtig oder Falsch!
Also einfach die Früchte drauf.
Okay. Doch, es gibt ein Falsch.
Achtung!
Und zwar, wenn ihr Kiwi oder zum Beispiel Ananas nehmt.
Dann wird es bitter,
wenn ihr ein Milchprodukt habt,
also jetzt gerade Sahne oder Quark.
Weil da einfach Enzyme drin sind,
die das Ganze dann bitter schmecken lassen.
Bei der veganen Version wäre das egal.
Aber, wie gesagt, nur bei Kiwi und Ananas
müsst ihr ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und ich hole jetzt noch Minzblätter.
Die kommen hier gleich noch mit drauf.
Und die Schokolade,
da mache ich jetzt einfach Röllchen mit einem Sparschäler.
Die kommen noch so drauf.
Zack.
[Musik]
Immer, wenn ich das Dessert mache,
weine ich fast,
weil es einfach so schön ist.
Das ist echt so.
Und dann die Erdbeeren vom Klaus drauf,
vom Bauern. Einfach die besten Erdbeeren!
Fertig!
Oh, noch die restlichen Erdbeeren
und dann bin ich fertig.
Dann können wir gleich probieren!
[Musik]
Also ich finde, rein optisch
sieht man gar nichts!
Also es sieht wirklich aus wie eine ganz normale Baiserplatte.
Ich habe sie jetzt nur länger drin lassen müssen,
damit sie einfach trocknet.
Da muss man einfach gucken.
Aber die löst sich jetzt auch super ab.
Das Eton Mess, das ist ja auch im Inneren,
also wie bei einem Pavlova,
einfach so ein bisschen noch feucht und marshmallowartig.
Von daher passt das perfekt!
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
statt normaler Sahne vegane Sahne
Hier habe ich noch ein bisschen Orangenpaste
und Vanilleextrakt für den Geschmack.
Ich mache jetzt einfach
ein bisschen einen anderen Geschmack.
Erdbeeren.
Brombeeren, die sind jetzt aus dem TK,
weil ich keine frischen hatte.
Und dunkle Schokolade.
Da nehme ich Zartbitterschokolade,
weil die von Natur aus vegan ist.
Was ich an veganer Sahne sehr mag, ist,
dass sie schneeweiß ist.
Also die wird jetzt auch steifgeschlagen.
Ihr könntet hier auch San-apart dazu nehmen,
wenn ihr möchtet.
San-apart ist ja auch vegan.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich möchte es ja hier
eher so ein bisschen cremiger haben und nicht standfest.
Vanille.
Orange.
Ihr könnt auch den Abrieb einer Orange nehmen
oder Zitrone.
Aber ich finde, hier passt Vanille und Orange ganz gut.
Was man nur beachten muss,
wenn man doch San-apart nimmt,
dass es dann nicht mehr glutenfrei ist.
Also so die Variante ist glutenfrei,
mit San-apart dann nicht mehr.
Muss man nur wissen.
[Musik]
Hier nehme ich jetzt ein paar Brombeeren,
gebe sie hier rein.
So kann ich nämlich die Creme ein bisschen marmorieren.
Wenn es klappt.
Oder sind sie noch zu gefroren?
Okay, sie sind noch zu gefroren.
Egal.
Dann ohne Marmoreffekt.
Die flutscht so ein bisschen anders.
Merkt ihr das?
>> JOSH: Ja,
ich habe es gemerkt.
Sie hat mich fast getroffen.
>> SALLY: Hast du es gemerkt, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es halt so krass.
Eigentlich ist ja Baiser schon weiß,
aber das ist einfach so
weiß hoch drei.
Komm, ich kriege noch einen Marmoreffekt hin.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Pech gehabt.
>> SALLY: Egal.
Ich habe jetzt überall Sahne an mir.
Nicht überall!
Okay.
Die Erdbeeren viertel ich jetzt noch.
O Mann!
Bei manchen lasse ich jetzt sogar das Grün dran.
Nicht, weil es die vegane Version ist,
sondern einfach, weil es schön ist.
O Mann!
[Musik]
Schwarze Schokolade,
also dunkle Schokolade.
Ich höre mal auf jetzt, Quatsch zu machen.
Okay.
Ich konzentriere mich wieder.
Ich merke so seit ein paar Tagen,
beim Dreh mache ich nur noch Quatsch.
>> JOSH: Das sind schon viele Tage!
>> SALLY: Viele Tage?
>> JOSH: Ja, schon viele Tage.
>> SALLY: Schon viele Tage Quatsch?
>> JOSH: Ja, schon viele Tage Quatsch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt nehme ich hier die Zartbitterschokolade
und mache hier auch diese Röllchen.
Ich kann auch seriös, Josh!
[Musik]
Okay.
Ihr habt euch mein Eton Mess gewünscht.
Hier habt ihr sogar die vegane Version!
Und die werden wir gleich verkosten.
Hm.
[Musik]
Ein bisschen.
Also rein optisch, finde ich, macht es kaum einen Unterschied.
Heute darf Philipp probieren!
Ta-daa!
Hi, Philipp!
>> PHILIPP: Hi!
>> SALLY: Jetzt fragt ihr euch: Wer ist Philipp?
Philipp hat gerade unseren Feigenbaum gerettet.
Ja.
>> PHILIPP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn der Feigenbaum,
der war leider zu klein in dem Kübel.
Jetzt haben wir ihn umgesetzt.
Und dann kam der Philipp,
hat mit dem Josh und Murat zusammen
den Baum umgesetzt.
>> PHILIPP: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Philipp, heute ist dein Glückstag!
Denn heute gibt es Eton Mess,
ein Dessert mit Baiser.
Ich habe jetzt zwei verschiedene Varianten gemacht.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Hier einmal mit
Brombeeren und Erdbeeren.
Und hier mit so Himbeeren.
Ja.
Und du kannst mal beide probieren
und mir sagen, wie dir beide schmecken.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
Gibt es eine Reihenfolge, wie probieren.
>> SALLY: Nö.
>> PHILIPP: Einfach machen, was ich will.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich bin mal gespannt.
Du darfst auch richtig ehrlich sein!
Also richtig ehrlich
>> SALLY: Feedback geben.
>> PHILIPP: Ja. Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich habe ihm nichts gesagt darüber.
Ich bin gespannt!
Auf jeden Fall was sehr Sommerliches.
>> PHILIPP: Also das finde ich jetzt,
genau, für den Sommer richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIPP: Vor allem mit der Erdbeere.
>> PHILIPP: Also das schmeckt mir jetzt sehr gut.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIPP: Hm.
>> SALLY: Probier mal noch die Variante.
>> PHILIPP: Was war das noch?
Brombeere hast du gesagt, gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Vielleicht kannst du hier auch
das Stück mit Erdbeere probieren.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Für wissenschaftliche Zwecke
ist das jetzt sehr wichtig,
dass wir noch den direkten Erdbeervergleich haben.
>> PHILIPP: Ich muss irgendwie sagen...
Soll ich die da packen mit dem Grün drauf?
>> SALLY: Egal.
>> PHILIPP: Ja?
>> SALLY: Das Grün kann man übrigens mitessen
bei den Erdbeeren.
>> PHILIPP: Ah, guck mal. Kann das dranbleiben?
>> SALLY: Das ist sehr gesund!
Also ich bin gespannt.
Ich sage dir auch gleich, was der Unterschied war.
Aber erst will ich von dir
dann praktisch ehrliches Feedback.
>> PHILIPP: Hm.
Mmh!
>> PHILIPP: Da war jetzt ein Biss dabei,
wo der Teig anders war.
Der war jetzt ein bisschen crunchy.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIPP: Mh.
Also auf den ersten Geschmack hin würde ich sagen,
dass mir das ein bisschen
ein bisschen besser schmeckt.
>> PHILIPP: Aber ich weiß nicht ganz genau warum.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wie schmeckt das hier?
>> PHILIPP: Ich bin kein so Fan von Brombeeren.
Vielleicht ist das so das...
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> PHILIPP: Ja, das Ding.
>> SALLY: Krass!
>> PHILIPP: Aber...
>> SALLY: Und das Stück mit der Erdbeere?
>> PHILIPP: War schon lecker.
Ja.
Also, wenn da jetzt nur Erdbeeren drin wären zum Beispiel,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIPP: dann würde ich das verputzen auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt erzähle ich dir was.
Und dann haut es dich von den Socken!
>> PHILIPP: Ich bin gespannt!
>> SALLY: So.
Also das ist ein ganz normales Baiser mit Eiweiß und Zucker,
mit Sahne und Quark.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und das ist vegan!
Aus Kichererbsenwasser!
>> PHILIPP: Oh! Okay.
>> PHILIPP: Das ist cool.
>> SALLY: Ich habe hier das Baiser
aus Kichererbsenwasser gemacht,
also statt Eiweiß einfach Kichererbsenwasser.
>> PHILIPP: Das Baiser ist dieser Teig, oder was?
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
>> PHILIPP: Krass!
>> SALLY: Krass, oder?
>> PHILIPP: Aber das hat man jetzt wirklich nicht geschmeckt,
muss ich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also ich finde, bei der veganen Sahne
hat man immer so einen bitteren Nachgeschmack,
so ein bisschen.
Wenn man es nicht weiß,
>> SALLY: schmeckt man es vielleicht nicht sofort raus.
>> PHILIPP: Ja. Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde es einfach krass,
was man mit dieser Kichererbsen-
mit dem Kichererbsenwasser machen kann.
>> PHILIPP: Das habe ich jetzt gar nicht gewusst.
>> SALLY: Weil wir haben bei uns zwei Veganer im Haus und
wir denken immer an die.
>> PHILIPP: Das, dass es so ein bisschen fester wird,
wie kriegt man das dann hin?
>> SALLY: Das kannst du genauso aufschlagen wie Eiweiß.
>> SALLY: Also hat ja auch Proteine und dann...
>> PHILIPP: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Hat genau ausgesehen wie Baisermasse.
Beim Backen war es ein bisschen
hat es länger gedauert, bis es durchtrocknet.
>> PHILIPP: Hm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ansonsten...
Also ich finde den Vergleich halt krass irgendwie,
>> SALLY: wenn man sich das überlegt.
>> PHILIPP: Also wären jetzt, glaube ich,
>> PHILIPP: da die Blaubeeren drauf gewesen
und die Himbeeren...
>> SALLY: So praktisch gleich belegt.
>> PHILIPP: Genau.
Dann hätte ich da gar keinen Unterschied gemerkt,
>> PHILIPP: bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
>> SALLY: Krass!
>> PHILIPP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Also,
Philipp, vielen Dank für das Verkosten!
>> PHILIPP: Ja. Vielen Dank, dass ich hier mal
>> PHILIPP: probieren durfte!
>> SALLY: Möchtest du jemanden noch grüßen?
>> PHILIPP: Ich würde mal gerne meine Oma grüßen,
>> PHILIPP: die Oma Elfriede,
>> SALLY: Das habe ich mir gedacht!
>> PHILIPP: und meine Freundin, die Theresa.
>> PHILIPP: Die guckt das nämlich auch gerne an.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SALLY: Hallo, Oma Elfriede!
Hallo, Theresa!
Ich grüße euch auch ganz lieb!
>> PHILIPP: Da freuen sie sich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also
viel Spaß beim Nachbacken der klassischen
und der veganen Version!
Probiert es gerne mal aus!
Gebt mir ein Feedback!
Und die Rezepte findet ihr wie immer auf sallys-blog.de
oder in der App.
Danke schön!
>> PHILIPP: Danke schön!
>> SALLY: Du darfst natürlich auch aufessen.
Ja, Sarah, es tut mir leid. Ich habe dich ausgetauscht.
Es tut mir so leid!
Aber Philipp war da und ich dachte so: Hey,...
>> PHILIPP: Also das war jetzt echt richtig geil!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich habe mir so gedacht: Komm, jetzt haben wir einen
Verkoster da, der einfach so unvoreingenommen hier probiert.
Und...
>> PHILIPP: Was sind diese weißen...
>> SALLY: Das ist weiße Schokolade
und hier habe ich Zartbitter,
weil weiße Schokolade ist nicht vegan.
>> PHILIPP: Ah, okay.
Und Zartbitterschokolade ist schon vegan,
weil da keine Vollmilch drin ist.
>> PHILIPP: Klar.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also eigentlich muss man echt nicht viel austauschen.
Ich habe eigentlich nur
hier die Sahne ausgetauscht und das Eiweiß.
>> PHILIPP: Also das ist echt so ein richtiges Sommerdessert.
>> SALLY: Und Sarah.
>> PHILIPP: Also das ist echt gut!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> PHILIPP: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Komm, Sarah. Willst du auch probieren?
Komm. Wir lassen noch Sarah, die Fachfrau,
die darf auch noch probieren. Okay?
>> SALLY: Komm. Machen wir hier.
>> PHILIPP: Ich bin kein Fachmann, oder wie?
>> SALLY: Du bist auch Fachmann.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Jetzt kommt die Fachfrau.
Jetzt haben wir beides, Fachmann und Fachfrau.
Wir bleiben jetzt alle drei im Bild.
Komm, Sarah, schnapp dir einen Löffel.
Ich hole dir gleich deinen Spreißel raus.
>> SARAH: Das war eins meiner Lieblingsrezepte
aus dem Buch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Komm, stell dich mal zwischen uns.
Dann haben wir deinen Ton auch schön.
>> PHILIPP: Ach so, so.
>> SALLY: Genau. Dann haben wir so.
Hast du einen Löffel.
>> SARAH: Ja, ich sollte mir einen holen, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich muss echt sagen,
das vegane lässt sich ein bisschen besser schneiden.
>> PHILIPP: Macht das einen Unterschied, wie lange man...
Also von der Zubereitungszeit her?
>> SALLY: Mhm, nur Backzeit.
Also hier habe ich 45 Minuten gebacken
und hier, glaube ich, über eine Stunde sogar.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Probier doch mal!
>> SARAH: Guck mal. Ich probiere.
Oha, das ist schon...
>> SALLY: Du musst ein bisschen lauter reden.
>> SARAH: Es ist schon weich.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt probier mal die.
>> SARAH: Die Minze!
>> SALLY: Die Minze!
>> SALLY: Gell? Die Minze macht es auch bei dem,
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: glaube ich, so.
>> PHILIPP: Ja, das stimmt.
Das Minzblatt. Ja.
>> SARAH: Hier habe ich keins.
>> PHILIPP: Du kriegst noch eins drauf.
Ja, genau.
>> SARAH: Danke!
Hast du einen Unterschied geschmeckt?
>> PHILIPP: Ich glaube, nur wegen den Brombeeren,
weil ich nicht so der Brombeerfan bin,
aber ansonsten war das lecker eigentlich.
Sag was!
>> SALLY: Rein mit!
>> PHILIPP: Rein damit!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber krass, oder?
>> SARAH: Da ist Orange noch mit drin, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja, genau!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Hm.
>> JOSH: Feinschmecker.
>> SALLY: Die Feinschmecker hier!
>> PHILIPP: Das weiß natürlich schon
die Fachfrau hier, gell?
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss schon sagen,
der Philipp hat das echt gut gemacht.
Du kannst öfter vorbeikommen!
>> PHILIPP: Okay, mache ich.
>> SARAH: Zum Probieren.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIPP: Muss ich dann jedes Mal
einen Baum rumlupfen, oder?
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> SALLY: Das machen wir dann ohne.
>> SARAH: Also ich glaube, das hält sich im Rahmen.
>> PHILIPP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ach, wir haben einen großen Garten.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> PHILIPP: Ja.
>> SARAH: Also ich schmecke auch keinen Unterschied.
>> SALLY: Wahnsinn, oder?
>> SARAH: Außer die Orange.
>> SALLY: Ich bin voll...
>> SARAH: Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Ich bin voll geflasht davon!
>> SARAH: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Das ist aus Kichererbsenwasser?
Also, wenn ihr das nächste Mal
Kichererbsenwasser übrig habt,
macht einfach Baiser draus.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Gell?
Tschüss!
>> PHILIPP: Good bye!
>> SALLY: Das ist auch noch deins.
>> SARAH: Kannst du jetzt?
>> SALLY: Ich hole dir jetzt deinen Spreißel raus.
Komm, ich verarzte dich.
>> SARAH: Mama Sally!
[Musik]